bonjour alafé wakili merci de répondre à
nos questions sur arte france pourquoi
l'obtention maintenant de ces passeports
son passeport diplomatique délivré avec
l'accord de l'actuel président ivoirien
alassane ouattara
maintenant peut-être parce que le
gouvernement ivoirien a estimé que
c'était le moment par rapport à la
procédure qui était en cours et qui est
toujours un coût encore peut-être aussi
aux français que c'est assez tôt mais
l'essentiel c'est que cela se soit fait
maintenant enfin et à quand le retour en
côte d'ivoire pour laurent gbagbo
du coup selon son avocat et il pourrait
revenir en décembre c'est possible
ce n'est pas impossible l'avocat dit que
les discussions sont confiés à monsieur
assoa adou qui est chargée d'un train
comptes avec le gouvernement sous
étudier les modalités de ce retour parce
que c'est l'ancien chef d'état vous avez
vu que l'ambassade et un représentant du
gouvernement ivoiriens se sont déplacés
pour lui et m le passeport
cela signifie que il est traité comme un
ancien chef de l'état et à ce type là
sont arrivés bras se lancer des
discussions même s'il estimait que son
passeport ne devait pas fait l'objet des
discussions et des tractations
maintenant c'est pas un simple citoyen
qui résonne en côte d'ivoire c'est un
ancien chef de l'état il sait lire un
certain nombre de prérogatives davantage
et des dispositions à prendre aussi par
le gouvernement ivoirien plan que cette
discussion qui n'a pas pu se ferait qu'à
tous étaient indirectes attendant sur la
tendance à des venues formelle à travers
la personne et quel pourrait être le
rôle de laurent gbagbo dans la
résolution de la crise politique on se
souvient de l'élection présidentielle
controversée à la fin du mois d'octobre
que il voudra jouer mais aussi que son
parti voudra lui donner l'occasion
l'ouest est aussi le conteste il est
évident que il a un rôle important à
jouer et que qu'il ne voudra pas être
simplement spectateur il voudrait tout
ça va arriver
et est ce qu'il pourrait y avoir des
conséquences dans la rue du coup cette
arrivée de laurent gbagbo
tout cela fait partie des discussions à
entamer des discussions à régler les
modalités au niveau de la sécurité et
dispositions pratiques à prendre
est ce que il a en quoi ce stade et ce
qu'il a besoin de bain de foule
parce qu'il a besoin de la rue on ça va
sauter des discussions d'échangés se
demander l'accord avec le gouvernement
tout reste possible il faut espérer que
la bonne volonté et la bonne
compréhension et respect de conciliation
et des dialogues dati tout le monde mais
ce qu'il a vraiment encore un avenir en
côte d'ivoire politiquement laurent
gbagbo à quoi s'attendre ces prochaines
semaines
voyez-vous la tendance consiste à dire
que non politique n'est jamais finie et
âmes est terminée tout dépend de sa
capacité à appréhender les réalités
nouvelles et aussi à maintenir l'unité
de sa famille politique
parce que à présent il faudra bien
réussi cette question de l'unité avec
pascal affi n'guessan encore le voici
amour à l'épreuve il faudra bien régler
cette affaire
disons que le gouvernement ivoirien le
voici donc s'il a ainsi c'est réglé ça
peut ouvrir d'autres perspectives
il tombe dit ans qui a la vie à de
l'espoir il tant que nos politiques en
vie ils sont toujours compter avec lui
merci à la féuo qui est d'avoir répondu
à nos questions
mais je rappelle que vous êtes le
directeur de l'intelligent d'abidjan
quotidien ivoirien